and i know this about you because it's
like you and i you don't really we don't
call each other no you're right and we
only see each other in this space yeah
and i don't even think we'd ever do
anything together which is sad to me but
i have called you and texted you before
yeah but if it's something if my life is
blowing up
when i found out headline you'll call
headlines
right right yeah i mean bobby's dying
you'll call right no
but in a random day like if it's raining
you you are you safe
but i don't know the la weather system
that's true but when you when you
announced the breakup what did i say i
called you did you yes i don't think you
went on the phone we did yes
let me just look i want to look at our
text exchanges all right phone off the
phone
i called you and i said how are you no i
i think i do i can prove it with chris
uh uh just
stefano
okay
so um let me just read some of this okay
we also never introduced chris we will
in a second we will in a second what it
is
christy d baby evan williams favorite
comic no no you know what you and i have
a really good text exchange actually
yeah go ahead read it i can't read this
stuff you can't i mean i i i i out of i
don't know why
just out of nowhere you sent me this
oh that's joey kamasa oh it is yeah but
why would you send me that just i wanted
you to know what was up yeah you could
send that if you could post it if you
want to send that put that on the
podcast yeah and then you love that then
you sent me this yep that's that was me
laying down um
i believe i had a fever that night yeah
yeah so you're right i haven't sent you
any photos no i sent you photos yeah so
that's me that's you that's me because
and i'm the bad guy because remember
what i said to you you know a few days
ago i said how are you coping i said i
would assume that these things
personally have been going on for a long
time but now but now publicly since
you've made a statement it's going to
get difficult and i want you to let you
know what i'm hearing you said i don't
want to talk and talk about that you
said after you know evan williams
so you very quickly brush it off well
that's because because
the reason why is because i called you
not because of my personal life yeah but
because i wanted you to see what you
thought of this but while he has you on
the phone he wants to know what how your
heart when i'm calling for one thing i
need to get that overwhelmed okay yeah
right and how about this
in an effort to you when cause you had
call i we were playing phone tag but
when you called me back
i went because i knew how important it
was that you i thought maybe you're
calling about this that maybe you just
need someone to talk to i was trying
showing my daughter how to ride a bike
with just taking the training wheels off
and i let go of the of the seat handle
to pick every call and she fell
is that a real true story real true
story she was fine she fell into patch
of grass but she's like why'd you let me
go i was like bobby's on the phone oh
okay well then she's fine but she got up
off that bike yeah and guess what she
put herself back on that bike and and
continued to ride let's go there you go
you know what i don't like when you just
brought that up you know what i don't
like what when comics
kids don't know who their friends are oh
yeah you were upset that brooke
christopher's daughter christchurch
doesn't the daughter doesn't know who i
am well you're not even going to july
4th barbecue so i mean that's true
that's what i'm saying that's why i
wanted to go anyway you know what i mean
but your kid knows
because if i had a kid they would know
your name even though you have a [ __ ]
up last name it's hard to say my kid
knows who you are she thinks you're
mulan